there was an article in the new york
post that talks about un-canceling
that's going on now with some actors
where there are people who've been
canceled and now they're coming back and
they reference uh leia michelle from
glee
apparently she was cancelled whatever in
20 in june 2020 after she tweeted in
solidarity with black lives matter
and former co-star samantha ware a black
woman shot back that michelle had been
an onset bully
so apparently she was canceled for that
and then of course they bring up in the
article james franco who was accused by
five women of sexual misconduct in 2018
at the height of the metoo movement now
he's returning he's going to be acting
in a new film called
me you
so interesting me too
me you not me too but
i think it's interesting we did talk
about people getting canceled and
whatnot but what do you think has there
been enough backlash you think to the
cancelling of people now where you're
going to see people who were very
quickly canceled that are going to have
a comeback and like
what what do you think is off limits
like in in other words who has a chance
at a comeback and who doesn't what what
types of mistakes it's uh i mean i think
i don't even want to say mistakes but
and i'm and i'm gonna be honest with you
it's it's insane because and i'm i'm
i've seen personally
people that were canceled for really
messed up [ __ ] like but to me when it
comes to female [ __ ] like i mean just
right now deshaun watson playing for the
i don't know what team texas or whatever
24 women came forward uh the nfl was
just like all right six games you can't
play but you're he's not he's canceled
for six games but he's back i think
especially people that were cancelled
for i'm talking about like
messing with underage women and doing a
bunch of messed up [ __ ] the pandemic
kovit [ __ ] helped all all right
because yo in that moment people were
like cancel kill them and then they're
like oh [ __ ] pandemic
they completely forgot about all the
dirty [ __ ] that you did no matter
i'm being dead serious yet anything i'm
talking about
horrible [ __ ] with women people
what oh no oh no i remember this guy was
this guy was dope or we just we really
like this person and it's it's i i think
the people are starting to kind of like
well you know we're ruining people's
careers you're knocking them off when
you cancel somebody like who was that
girl that the daily wire hired she got
canceled
oh uh carl uh
tina carano like like and i'm happy that
there's other windows there's other
avenues but you know some of these
people that's their livelihood and they
make a mistake that's the thing about
canceling somebody that we're human
beings but we're not jesus christ
walking around just i'm never making a
mistake sometimes i say messed up [ __ ]
i've been on stage i
said something really messed up i should
have been punched in my face i admit it
i mess up i'm a person yeah you
apologize you move on if you don't have
the the decency to just say listen my
bad not blaming everybody else i'm i
messed up apologize and move on yeah but
there's going back they're starting to
ease up because you know this time heals
all wounds yeah especially with like a
franco i don't know because i wasn't i
have no idea i never met the guy i don't
know [ __ ] about him but
time time people solely are just like oh
okay okay i mean the weinsteins and all
these guys they're done bye
you've caused so much [ __ ] damage to
people's lives and you know money and
those people are like messed up some of
these girls like that rose rolling she's
[ __ ] up you [ __ ] these people up
good bye get out of here yeah i think
there's a difference between like
patterns of behavior that are clearly
and objectively destructive and then
people who misspeak or are just human
make a mistake i always used to talk
about the death of the apology like now
it doesn't matter you come out you
apologize nobody cares but i do think
there's enough backlash now where there
are different avenues like you mentioned
the daily wire that had hired gina there
are avenues like that pop up for people
now in places that refuse to abide by
this canceled culture which is good and
there's also like they're running out of
talent because it's like everyone is
gonna say something stupid at one point
or another there's gonna be a trail
especially now with social media being
what it is i think about like my son
i think about like these kids who have a
trail starting at like 10 years old
that's like
there there's going to be something no
one's going to be able to run for
president based if we do this no one's
going to be able to do anything because
you're going to be able to look back and
be like oh it's 17. they said this and
now there's a video of it out there like
there has to be a way as a society to
just like
acknowledge that people are people at
the end of the day i think it's coming
back around now and you're going to have
a lot of these people that
made mistakes again not a pattern of
behavior that was like repeatedly
destructive not like a rapist or
something horrible but you know people
who just misspoke
and they're gonna have second shot i
have a question for you what about a
cancer culture towards someone like um
and i talked about this yesterday
someone like chris brown he beat the
crap out of rihanna and he was canceled
for a little bit but he kind of came
back you know i don't think he's at his
peak like he was at one point but he's
like we're gonna have the same career
that he had um and it is it's crazy too
because any moment like this but
shouldn't that be someone who's canceled
because abuse though that's what that's
the distinction i think like somebody
who's like for me anyway someone who's
like you rape somebody you're a
repeatedly an abusive person like that
to me is different than like somebody
who does a comedy bit and like offends
somebody or has a slip of the tongue or
says something they're not they're not
causing you physical harm words don't
harm like i know people say now they do
but that's not the same thing as like
punching somebody in the face or it's
it's different
yeah i mean and in that situation and i
mean as the years went by we learned
that she was
hitting him and beating him in the car
and he you know he retaliated but i mean
that's a complex story that's a really
messed up story and that's why it's like
but that once you heard that
with that picture there all you thought
about was he beat this piece he beat the
[ __ ] out of her that was it nobody cared
about the story or do you think though
because he was also an attractive person
who did it that also affect how far he
got canceled
i think sometimes it depends on who the
audience is like athletes get away with
a lot 100
i think it depends on like how
replaceable that person is like you're
an all-star player and whatever you're
not going to be easily replaceable
they'll figure out a way to like talk
their way out of that like six-game
suspension whatever um and i do
sometimes think it's political like if
that person's politics lean right
forget it like they'll be very quick too
because you know what they do then they
do a deep dive and they find one thing
and then they go back and they dig up a
trail and then they try to just
wreck you like you're ben shapiro and
you make a slip of the tongue like good
luck yeah you know luckily he has his
own company but hollywood's not going to
be making any excuses yeah and you just
you just made a great point like the the
the level of your talent it really
decides on where you're at like that's
right the sean the guy the football
player
if that because he go he's not like he's
a great he's a dope dope player right
slap on the i mean 24 goes girls are
coming out still left and right that
he's inappropriate he touched me blah
blah if that guy was just like a third
string like fullback you never would see
this guy ever again be in the news
canceled done done done so it's how much
money are you are you still making these
money companies money are you kidding me
bro the nfl they you should they're very
lenient you could just be live on camera
beating the show but he's like hey he
knows how to run all right that guy can
run through the game
and it's sad
but you better not you better be
you know if you're a girl and you're an
abusive relationship with a football
player they're not gonna cancel that guy
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]